switchin Theatre Russia Austria 2020
2021 ceremony is concluded we will now
proceed to the press conference of the
President of the Russian Federation
Vladimir Putin and the president of the
Austrian Republic
Alexander mr. president ladies and
gentlemen we are happy to welcome
Alexander and rebellin and his spouse
here in Russia it is notable that a year
from today on the 15th of May 2020 will
mark the 60-year anniversary since the
signing of the founding agreement the
agreement signed by the victor states of
the of world war ii and the democratic
country of Austria this was an important
document of post-war reconstruction in
Europe that guaranteed a peaceful
development of Austrian I'd like to
underline that over decades between
Russia and Austria we've had relations
built on principles of friendship mutual
respect and respect for our own
interests we have an intensive political
dialogue I have met mr. van der Berlin
in Vienna last year I'm in constant
contact with the federal Chancellor of
Austria mr. Sebastian Kurtz just
recently I've seen I've met him in
Beijing
today's talks with the president of
Austria have been traditionally friendly
and businesslike we saw an interest in
both Russia and Austria to proceed in
further development of our ties we have
businesses of Russia and Austria have
met and we have discussed further steps
for the development of our cooperation
Austria is a key Russian partner
economic partner in Europe that is why
we talked a lot about the investment
cooperation last year and our trade
turnover increased by over 40 percent
and reached as almost six billion
dollars since the start of this year we
shall turn over rose by 70 percent more
the investment of rushing to Austria is
over 27 billion million dollars we have
reached such results thanks to the work
of the Russian Austrian Commission on
trade cooperation which saw its last
meeting in May last year on the
sidelines of this in Petersburg
International Economic Forum by the way
the delegation from Austria was one of
the most widely represented delegations
on the forum I hope that this year our
Austrian friends will take an active
participation in the forum as well we
are waiting
Austrian industrialists at the inner
prom exhibition and at the summit for
industrialization that will take place
in July in the Katherine Berg we have
invited Sebastien Kurtz the federal
Chancellor to visit these events as well
and I hope that he will lead the
Austrian delegation I'd like to note
that Austrian and Russian companies are
closely cooperating in a number in
multiple projects in machine building in
high technologies in telecommunications
our country has over 1200 companies that
operates with Austrian capital and who
aim for a long-term operations in our
country and expansion of their
operations for example such companies as
Ross hydro and others are planning to
start production of equipment for for
electric plants in Russia the green
source company and core value company
will be launching in the uliana
region they can the production of the
components for solar energy stations we
had signed the declarations earlier for
cooperation and we are planning 28
cooperation projects to that amount to
three billion dollars in value Russia
for many years have been providing
energy to Austria last year we had 12
billion cubic meters for Russian gas
provided exported to Austria we are
cooperating in the creation of the of
the Nord Stream to project Russia values
Austria's support of this project which
will help provide the energy security of
the entire European continent an
important part of our cooperation is
bilateral contacts and inter-regional
contacts in March this year there was a
we held the there was the Russian
regions day held in Austria hundreds of
representatives all four Austrian
businesses took part in this event and I
would also like to know the of course
the valuable cultural and humanitarian
ties this year we have
the cross-cultural year of of the youth
of Russia and Austria we have agreed to
hold in 2021 to 22 the year of
literature in theater in Russia and
Austria we are already starting efforts
to popularize literature and theater of
our countries in both our countries the
same goes for the use of and the
teaching of our language in Austria and
the Austrian and the German language in
Russian we are developing times in terms
of civil society right after these talks
we will meet the members of the the
Sochi dialogue civil society forum we've
agreed to do that in Vienna last year
and I hope that this meeting will allow
us to strengthen ties between the people
of peoples of our countries in sport and
industry and education and culture and
in conclusion I'd like to thank the
president of Austria and all of our
colleagues for this productive and very
constructive dialogue we've had today I
am confident that the agreements we've
reached will help further develop the
entire range of our cooperation efforts
thank you thank you very much for
inviting me here to Sochi and thank you
for a very warm welcome we've just had
very interesting as some staff dogs we
had every opportunity to change your
opinions thoughts and certain issues
traditionally Austrian Russia have had
very good relations it's true for this
century and for this century which is
that one mr. pudding mansion the 1945
agreement yes today we are celebrating
its anniversary in 1955 this agreement
was signed in Austria declaring its
independence in continuation of the 1943
Moscow declaration it was signed so it
is true that we can say that our history
of good relations goes back into history
we are determined to improve our
relations on a number of tracks I'm
pleased to inform mr. president that the
Salzburg museum is ready to return this
autumn to Russia those antiques that
were relocated during the Second World
War from Russia and today among other
things we discussed the junior Kies
institution the Jewish acquire
institution we talked about culture we
talked about science energy economy our
cooperation in these sectors goes back
decades last year we celebrated the
fiftieth anniversary of the start of
cooperation between our cooperation and
richer cooperation and gas prom so you
can see that this old goes back to the
times of the Soviet Union so that's the
kind of cooperation we are proud to have
hundreds of companies their branch
offices are situated in Austria the
previous president of the Austrian
Chamber of Commerce said that Austin
companies come here to Russia to stay
and that is not a threat no I'm talking
about cooperation about serving your
mutual interests as for international
relations relations between the EU and
it is no secret that our predecessors
were not satisfied with relation between
Russia and Ukraine I can say that I
would only welcome a betterment of these
relations I would like to see the Minsk
agreements implemented but let's be
realistic we need to wait and see how
things will be going on after the
parliamentary election in Ukraine this
year as I said already we've been saying
one the same thing for years we need to
maintain dialogue even though sometimes
we disagree a dialer should be
maintained at all times the discussion
we had on the issue of the yesterday's
visit of state secretary Pompeo to
Russia was very interesting we discussed
Iran and recent developments around this
issue we discussed probable consequences
and implications for relations between
Russia and the EU I think you know that
the joint comprehensive plan of action
has suffered a blow after Iran decided
to pull back on the number of its
commitments you know that sanctions may
be introduced and the US has already
introduced certain sanctions against
Iran and it may impose sanctions on the
EU members for cooperation with Iran
that is why I think it's good that mr.
president but then Putin I would be
joining the Saudi dialogue meeting to
discuss this and other issues I also
think it is very good that this forum
it's so representative we have
established ties at different levels
thanks to that forum at the level of
culture and science it's not about
politics only and that is very good in
my opinion they such a dialogue forum it
should be further promoted and we both
understand that it helps to make our
relations better we can also cooperate
with France in Germany on that track I
think and again I would like to use this
opportunity to invite you to Salzburg
mr. Putin to visit the festival next
year we'll be celebrating the 100th
anniversary of that festival and that is
why I think it would be very good for
you to come and visit it it will be very
interesting and many performers many
just will come from Russia to
participate because you see Russia's
contribution to that festival is
enormous Russia is a traditional
participant so it would be a pleasure to
see you there
and again thank you for inviting me here
to Sochi I was really pleased to see
this place this is a new place for me
it's not a traditional visit to a
capital is something different so thank
you now we'll have an opportunity for
Austrian and Russian journalists to ask
two questions each we will start with
our friends from Austria as dentists in
Austria press agency good afternoon
I would like to ask you a question about
the meeting with Pompeo Vladimir Putin
mr. president you said that both sides
take interest in restoring relation
between Russia and the United States
what kind of environment should be
established for that to happen and are
you ready to have a one-on-one meeting
with Donald Trump what do you think
about such a meeting taking place in
Vienna where the joint comprehensive
plan of action was signed well
Vienna is a good place to hold the talks
on the highest level but the most recent
upcoming opportunity will have to I have
to meet I will have to meet Trump is
during the meeting of the g20 in Japan
if our American partners are ready to
continue our contacts and I have said
that on many opportunities we are open
to dialogue anywhere any place any time
including Vienna as for our bilateral
relations we have discussed that
yesterday too with the u.s. state
secretary and we I've had a conversation
with mr. Trump on telephone too and I
feel that American partners our American
partners are interested in restoring
relations at least that's that's the
issues and we've outlined the issues of
mutual interest without lines when I've
had my talks with the mr. Pompeo
yesterday we've talked about strategic
stability and security in the world
issues of non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons we and the New START treaty will
be expiring in 2021 and we need to know
what to do about it if we want to extend
it we need to start negotiations talks
about that as soon as possible we have
mutual interests
in the area of resolving regional
conflicts I'm talking about Afghanistan
Syria and a number of other areas there
are multiple areas in the world quite a
lot of them actually unfortunately and
without our active participation this
work words is unlikely to be very
effective now finally there's the North
Korean issue we are of course interested
in resolving it in such a way that all
sides are satisfied with the results and
of course the nuclear problem with Iran
the jcpoa is a very acute issue related
to the entire array of the situations in
the Middle East so we have a lot of
topics to discuss a lot of areas to
discuss including the economy yesterday
I said that the US has become the
world's largest producer of oil and we
need to see how this affects the oil
market there are other areas for us to
discus most note that well the most of
the Boeing planes are produced from
Russian titanium and we we know that and
we ready to discuss that we have many
other areas to discuss but it's not
about us it's about our American
counterparts about our American partners
when they are ready to for open dialogue
we will of course stay forward towards
them but we can see that that's a lot
being done for this to happen for
example the Mueller report has proven
that there was no kind of interference
of Russia in the American elections well
let's see what happens next and we
continue now russia's journalist turned
please good afternoon
vietnam estate my question goes to both
leaders
what do you think about the u.s. frats
of probable sanctions I've no stream -
and can that Austrian company leave the
project because of these risks and I
mean the oil fowl company thank you I
believe one foul does not want to leave
that project should I repeat could you
help me Austria is not going to abandon
North stream tree our gas consortium it
has no plans of that kind we invested a
lot and we are ready to deliver on our
commitments even if the u.s. gas had
been cheaper than the Russian Siberian
gas that would not have changed a lot
given the current situation the US has
no economic reason whatsoever to change
its position so that's the situation
well if we're talking about when we're
talking about the notes 3 Morris and
some other projects we have talked about
that on many occasions I'd like to say
this again that under the pretense under
the guise of some political reasons what
we can see is happening is actually bad
faith competition and we know that their
product is not better in terms of
quality but they're trying to impose
their products on other potential
markets for them Austria is not the
largest country in the world but
to protect their interests it doesn't
require nuclear weapons all that
requires is political will and of course
companies have to deal with the pressure
coming from the US especially companies
working in the US market so there's this
is not say in mystery everyone knows
that but this is a sovereign decision of
a country of our partner country as far
as I know and fowl are ready to
cooperate with us to continue to
cooperate with us in the future despite
all kind of bad faith efforts from our
American colleagues I believe that other
companies realize that they are
responsible to for the development of
their countries economies the entire
energy of a country if it costs more
than the economy of the country on the
whole will be worse off in terms of
competition and others will use a
cheaper product so all of this at the
end of the day hinges on the political
will of our friends I believe that we
will complete the project and will lose
successful in that you know it's easier
to work with the Turks than with the
Europeans once mr. Erdogan makes a
decision he he does it he actually does
it while with our European colleagues we
continued to work on the same issue for
years for decades still the European
Union is an important partner of ours
and we are reaching 300 billion dollars
worth of cooperation it used to be four
hundred billion dollars still the Nord
Stream project
it's important and it's in the interests
of Europe and I think we will pull
through with it as they continue and
it's the hosting journalist mr.
president my question goes to Vladimir
Putin and I have a question for under
Bern mr. Bertie recently we've seen a
rise in tensions over the joint
comprehensive plan of action
what could Russia possibly do to save
their deal the Kremlin said that it
would want that agreement to stay alive
so what should be done to make that
happen and my second question what does
Europe expect from Russia do you think
that Russia will safe that agreement we
have always supported this treaty this
deal we've worked on it with our
partners and the key role in signing
this treaty was played by Iran itself
and by the United States and we were
close we helped them in the process of
reaching an agreement and so we it is
regretful it is regrettable that this
treaty this deal is collapsing because
we always stood for maintaining it after
the signing of the deal Iran became the
most transparent the most honest country
in this respect in the world and the the
I heard from IAEA officials that Iran is
completely and fully implementing the
the deal still our American colleagues
decided to decide it to withdraw and to
it is sad but I'm constantly in contact
with our Iranian of counterparts and we
believe of course it would be prudent
for Iran to remain part of the deal and
maybe some of our European friends
wouldn't be happy to hear this but the
Europe the Americans have withdrawn the
deal is collapsing and the Europeans can
cannot do anything to save the deal they
cannot work with Iran to somehow offset
the losses the economic losses Iran will
suffer but once Iran makes the decision
to withdraw from any kind of a deal or
anything everyone will forget that it
was the u.s. who initiated the collapse
of the deal and everyone in the world
the global opinion will be it is Iran's
fault
I have told about that I have told that
to Iranians on many occasions I don't
believe that they have any reason to
withdraw from the deal and I have said
that on multiple occasions we'll see
what happens next
Russia is not a fire brigade we I cannot
just go around saving everything that's
burning around us we have played our
part and we are ready and willing to
play this part in the future but it
depends largely not just on us but on
our partners on Europeans on the US and
only run itself fortunately I don't have
a lot to add to that the IAEA has
inspected Iran 13 times every time it
was proved there to run complied with
every obligation in took upon itself
according to the joint comprehensive
plan of action sanctions imposed by the
United States well that's
the decision America made these
sanctions they do not help to promote
international relations
there was no sufficient grounds for its
withdrawal that undermines trust Europe
believes that the fact that the u.s.
after it pulled out from the joint
comprehensive plan of action announced
sanctions against Tehran and that was
very provocative in parallel to that yes
said that all European companies that
would continue cooperating with Ron
would be sanctions too so we put two and
two and we can see how things will be
going further on the u.s. believes that
relations with certain companies are
more important that its relations with
Iran the EU so far hasn't come up with
the mechanism which would help us to
continue cooperation with Iran with
being honored for over a year
remember how it all started in Vienna
when decision to create such a mechanism
was first announced it's very laborious
work we decided to support Iran and the
impression I have is that any additional
pressure on Iran is going to undermine
the political relations even further no
matter how much we argue about the
probability of that happening but if the
US continues put impression around that
leads to certain kind of risk that a
crisis can happen as it happened in Iraq
couple of years ago and in Europe no one
wants that to happen and the last
question thank you very much Alex a
better off Rossio I have questions to
both presidents we've been following
these talks and the impression I have is
that the relations that the dialogue
between Russia and Austria is different
to that of between Russia and the EU
well the trade is better and the quality
of the Dalek is better
how much do yer appeal sanctions impede
cooperation between Russia and Austria
the EU the EU is tough line on Russia
has been Society now we have pragmatism
coming up do you think that a true
assumption well sanctions are always an
obstacle they are legitimate efforts
taking without taking into account the
UN Charter this is the the practice the
of our Western counterparts this is what
they do I understand that I believe that
nothing should be done in a unilateral
way but Russia is ready to find
compromise it is ready to search for
solutions of the most difficult problems
but not through sacrificing our
fundamental our essential national
interests but still we are very we're
not rigid we have trade turnover with
Austria with the you even with the u.s.
we had a 20% increase of trade yes the
the total amount is negligible but with
still saw a rock still saw growth and so
we saw growth in terms of turnover with
Europe and the whole before the crisis
it was over four hundred billion dollars
now it's reached 300 billion it and last
year it was about two hundred billion so
it rose by the bar by about 80 billion
and we export a lot of energy to Austria
and there was a an increase in the price
of energy of oil and gas and that might
partly explain that but we've also had
very good relations with France with
Italy with Germany with Austria well it
this is developing we are happy with the
way it is developing of course it would
be better if we had no political
obstacles any anything that politically
motivated to prevent us from reaching
our full potential as maybe about the
European Union countries themselves
through their sanctions lost about ten
billion euros and this was taking out of
the salaries and of the results of the
people working in Europe and these are
goods that were able they couldn't
export to us and I hope that this will
be overcome and we will be able to move
forward in the future more successful
economy wise I think that we have
already overcome the worst you know just
as good idea that we have certain well
for requisites for those sanctions
Crimean other issues
triggered the situation we have
generally I agree with Vladimir Putin
agree with sanctions they are damaging
to all of us
Austria first struggled a lot but now we
just redirected our trade and we used to
sell packaged products manufactured
goods we used to sell apples never thing
now we mostly sell our no house
machinery and our equipment so the
situation has changed but still the
situation is not satisfactory and no one
is going to argue with that I think
thank you
[Laughter]